Kenya Airways flight KQ 100 coming into
land at Heathrow this afternoon more
than eight hours after it took off from
Nairobi it was this flight on Sunday
from which a stowaway fell out of a
wheel Bay as the Boeing 787s
undercarriage came down over Clapham in
South London the body crashed to the
ground in the garden of a house in this
street where the tenant was sunbathing
the plane took off for the 4,000 mile
journey from Nairobi to London at half
past nine local time and climbed to an
altitude of 40,000 feet where
temperatures plunged to minus 57 degrees
the Dreamliner passed over offert
enrolled just after half-past three at
three and a half thousand feet and
landed at Heathrow just a few minutes
later over here we have dr. Daniel
Martin is the director of the center for
altitude space and extreme environment
medicine at UCL he says surviving at
such a height he's all but 29,000 feet
the summit of Everest is probably the
very limit of what humans can achieve
from an altitude perspective and that
takes weeks to acclimatize to get to the
summit of Everest this person will have
had less than an hour to get to that
altitude so there's no possibility
whatsoever of any acclimatization and
it's that very sudden exposure to a high
altitude which is so very dangerous
Sunday's flight landed at Heathrow on
time and with no damage to the aircraft
but food water and clothing left behind
by the stowaway
were found in the wheel bay there
Whittingham is chief executive of the UK
flight Safety Committee he says even if
you survive the altitude and extreme
cold and are in the final descent to
landing the danger still isn't over
while the pilots have warning of when
the undercarriage is coming down if
you're in the undercarriage bait you do
not so the probability is that even if
this individual was alert then there is
no warning the doors were just open and
if you're not ready you're out stowaways
in the undercarriage of planes are
surviving the ordeal rarest still this
young man emerged alive after a flight
from California to Hawaii five years ago
and in Kenya now an investigation is
underway into what happened on Sunday's
flight tickets woke everybody who scam